newt gingrich former speaker of the
house and author of beyond biden
joins me now all right speaker so when
you saw the picture of stacey abrams
grinning
with all those masked children in the
background what did you think
i thought it was just typical of the
power elite it's like watching governor
newsom at a football game with no mask
as he demands that the rest of the
california have a mask
i think that the hypocrisy and the
corruption
of our political elites and frankly many
of our richest people uh comes down to
almost a class warfare where the rest of
us are you know we're the incorrigibles
we're too stupid we don't know what
we're doing but luckily you have a
handful of people like stacy abrams
like hillary clinton who will solve our
problems for us now of course they can't
and they don't
but i thought it was a perfect
illustration of who stacy really is and
why i think she'll lose the governorship
this fall
yeah i mean when you're relying on
people that can't even solve problems in
their own lives to solve your problem
that is a major problem and you're right
speaker it's not about left and right
it's up and down now you have rich and
powerful people telling everybody else
below them what to do
no one's going to stand for that anymore
how much longer do you think this mass
craziness is going to go on
well i think all across the planet
you're seeing a rebellion this whole
truck driver effort for example in
canada which really reminds me of the
tractor kate against jimmy carter in
1979 i mean the truck drivers just got
sick of it and of course the response
which has shocked me well you know we
think of canadians as nice pleasant
people low-key well the canadian
government's reacted like a dictatorship
and has gone all out
to cause as much pain as they can has
even said you know if you provide them
gasoline or you provide them food uh the
truck drivers now you could be arrested
and i don't know what law there is that
blocks you from providing food and
gasoline to truckers but uh the the
local mayor in in ottawa the say the
national capitals decided
you know he's going to crush them and
that and you're seeing this kind of real
division i think everywhere it's the
nancy pelosi effect
uh you know what
she runs a dictatorship he used to be
called the house of representatives but
it's really pelosi's dictatorship
and it's the same kind of attitude
explain to the audience the
tractor rebellion against jimmy carter
quickly
sure what happened was farm farm incomes
had dropped dramatically
and so
the national farmers union organized
thousands of people now think about this
it's one thing to have big trucks to go
at a pretty good speed you suddenly had
coming towards washington from all over
the country people driving big tractors
at the speed of a tractor uh and they
finally all i was a freshman congressman
and you'd walk outside on the mall and
there were all these tractors everywhere
it was but but the the response was to
be sympathetic
not to try to find a way to lock them up
and that's the real change i think has
been how these elites
now think their job is uh to try to go
out and take normal everyday people and
throw them in jail because they don't do
what the elites want even if the elites
aren't doing what they claim they want
all right speaker gingrich thank you so
much for coming on jesse waters prime
time it was enlightening i did not know
about the tractor rebellion
glad to do it hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else